the coronavirus has yet to reach its
peak in Africa where many nations have
some of the weakest health care in the
systems excuse me in the world in South
Africa there are 50 reported deaths from
the disease and more than 2700 confirmed
cases but in one violent neighborhood
the crisis has brought about a change
that many did not think was possible
Debora patta is in Johannesburg with
South Africa under lockdown there's been
a 75% decrease in violent crime and it's
had a ripple effect in places like this
the community of Westbury known for its
relentless gang violence now unusually
calm but in another part of the country
rival gangs have gone one step further
these are some of the most dangerous
streets in South Africa the battleground
for rival Capetown gangs but it seems a
corona virus has achieved what the
police and the army could not what we're
seeing happening here today is is
literally America a truce between
warring gangs community pastor Andy
steel Smith works with gang members many
of whom are convicted killers but now
instead of plying drugs they are using
their skills to help the hungry the best
distributors in the country they know
how to distribute things say they're
used to distribute other other white
powders but still distributing things
and then they know everybody sworn
enemies now meet up regularly to parcel
up essential food items and deliver them
to those in desperate need so how does
it feel to be the good guy for a change
for now old feuds are forgotten
authorities however escaped ikal I don't
think it exonerates you when you've done
so much evil one good doesn't suddenly
good good D doesn't suddenly wipe it all
away maybe they can commit to slightly
more long term good
but pastor Steele Smith you guys didn't
think this would happen in our lifetimes
I'm alright yeah but you're doing good
things to the community together if I
died today and went to heaven I die a
happy man after more than three weeks
and locked on that truth appears to be
holding it may not last but for now it
is one of the unintended benefits of a
nation ordered to stay at home for CBS
this morning Saturday Debora patta
Johannesburg South Africa